well i think it's you know it's always
so cool to be able to like be in those
situations with
people that have gone through similar
experiences in life and
and um and i guess that's even when i
found with doing this show is you end up
realizing how much more similar we are
than than than not
and so you know you say like that
there's actually a lot of similar themes
in
your lives growing up
what would you say a coming you know
people like d wade or lewis hamilton or
you know you've been around some some a
lot of those kinds of people what do you
think like the most common themes are
um about their lives and especially like
writing a book that is you know letters
to a young athlete like i mean the the
there's got to be some common themes
that for sure by the way i got this um
when i was in after i went to austin to
the race i went to
ryan holidays painted porsche bookshop
and um
so that's all right
extra even more special than just your
boat yeah i have to thank ryan yeah we
went down there a while ago to see his
uh whole operation i think i did his
podcast there and the books had just
came in so
you know yeah that's so cool just to see
your work um in somewhere i mean that's
a success to me i guess for me that was
one of the challenges in writing this
book i wanted to
bring those common themes to light
um because that you know in my success
that's kind of
the thing that i found was that
we can all relate to each other there's
always this moment of truth to where
it's you have to make a decision on what
you're going to do
and then that doesn't mean everybody's
going to believe you there's going to be
a long tough road
you know that that's promised in
whatever goal you're trying to pursue
you know so for me in that reaching um
you know the pinnacle of my goals
winning championships
um being able to do
some great things play with the best
athletes in the world be the best
athlete in the world travel the world
win gold medals i mean you know the
chase goes on
i always say kind of
one of the fascinating things after
about after you accomplish the
championship is
they come out there they sweep up the
confetti
now it's about next season
you know and if you wanted people like
ah you know you don't get the credit
that you feel that you deserve and all
those things so
my thing was just to focus on the
journey
of um of what you're doing
make sure that every day you're working
toward a goal
and that's a good start
you know it can be so many challenges
that come your way and again we all have
that in common too
right i mean even for you i mean i could
only imagine you know being
a woman in in race sport like
the things that you have to endure the
challenges that you have to get over and
on top of that everybody is not
going to support you are not going to
believe in you but you can concentrate
on those that do
um you can build a very strong support
system in a very strong team around you
and you know if if that's not the case
if you're not feeling where you're
supposed to be then you know have the
courage to make some changes
i think that's easier said than done
because what that is self-confidence
right of course like it's a little
easier than when it's written it's all
done and we're like wow you know i just
you know i believed in myself it's like
in the moment of course like especially
the people listening that um especially
i think this this will get some you know
younger aspiring athletes and and it's
just like yeah of course it's easier
said than done so
what is it that how do you how do you
get the
confidence or where do you find it where
do you find the confidence to go i'm not
getting the kind of support i need i'm
not hanging around the right kind of
people
i'm not create having the right
discipline
um there's a lot of things that go into
it how do you have any awareness and
then like how do you get how do you get
to awareness
i think self-assessment is always a very
um good thing to do i mean you know
sometimes you have to sit um assess your
goals write down your goals if you need
to
um
be honest about where you are
and you know good bad or indifferent
there's still going to be a next step
regardless
um i'm kind of an organized person so
this is just my kind of what i do but i
always kind of self-assess and see where
i'm at how do i feel
um and you know sometimes that takes
investing time in yourself and i think
you know in the day-to-day
we can get away from that sometimes or a
person can become overwhelmed and they
won't work on what they need to work on
for themselves it'll just be
trying to work on that thing that
everyone thinks it should you know they
should be uh so for me
you know i always just try to keep that
in mind um
you know for me
um
maturing to where i am now i have five
children
like i said before so my first job is
being dad
and
i have to make sure that i'm in the
right head space every day
um to be able to talk to him to be able
to
let them know okay this is what we're
doing today we've got to finish school
we've got why because this is our goal
to be educated to have you know access
and be successful later on in life and
and then really kind of pick up from
there and go from there you know try my
best to stay present and
whatever the day brings along
you know try to dive fully into it
you know i always think about this with
athletes like you don't
feel like you really plan on retirement
there might be like an idea where you go
maybe in a few years maybe i'll play for
like five more maybe three more like
that's kind of the limit of what you
think about when you think about
retiring as an athlete because if you're
gonna play
or participate at the level that you you
need that you want to and that you
deserve to play at and participate at
you can't be thinking about retirement
so it either happens one of two ways
it's kind of you know an epiphany like
all of a sudden i'm just not into it
anymore or
you have something happen like with you
where you have blood clots and like all
of these things are physiological that
you can't do anything about and so i
think that's a lot of times how a career
ends for an athlete it tends to always
feel a little sudden because you can't
anticipate the moment you don't want to
play in anticipation you're playing all
in
but you've got the job of being a
basketball player and all the things
that go into that
um but then you talked about now you're
like my job now i'm a dad and so i'm
kind of curious like because those are i
mean they're both jobs for sure
but you know i'm guessing that there was
that point in time when you were playing
i don't know if you had all five of your
kids while you're playing or not but i'm
sure you started to have a couple of
them like you know
the the the job of basketball played the
played the primary role and now you have
like solid job of being a dad and that's
your your your main role and so you know
what are the what what did what can you
bridge the gap on because there's not a
lot of basketball players out there but
there's a lot of dads out there right
like what did you learn from basketball
that helps you being a dad it's all
about teamwork
whether you're the leader or the
follower um in order to accomplish great
things you have to have a a great team
be a part of a great team and and it
requires each person
to
facilitate what they facilitate to play
their role and i really got that from
uh
being in basketball i wrote about it in
my book checking your ego
um
one of the things that that i found
fascinating um in my career
was that i got to take part in a team to
where
i was the third leg of the stool which
is pretty still pretty good
well you know in in when we're all
shooting shots every basketball player
playing boy or girl out there when they
shoot that shot what are they doing on
the on in the playground or on their
backyard basketball they're counting
down
three two one and they're making the
shot if you miss it you redo it
you know and you can't go home until you
make it right can't go home until you
make it now nobody's necessarily
making the defensive play imagining that
or getting that rebound or getting that
block um in in terms of basketball uh
but all of those things happened to me
because i made the sacrifice and we all
made the sacrifice to be part of a
bigger team
um so
yeah was i frustrated that sometimes
that i didn't get more shots or
sometimes i felt i was being my
greatness was being overlooked sure you
know that's a part of the human process
but
all in all it was about my goal was to
be a part of a successful team at the
end of the day and i translate that
that's where i kind of
not kind of i bridge the gap uh with my
family because um
you know we all have our roles
we all have our jobs day to day we've
got to meet the requirements you know we
want to be a great family so this is
what we have to do you know we're taking
these holiday pictures let's go
everybody clothes on
[Laughter]
yeah yeah nine o'clock let's go you know
vacation all right let's go get those
bags we got to get them checked you know
it's uh tells you how many kids i have
so we're a large team when we move
so
you know it requires organization and
you know anytime we do something as a
family it's a big you know it's more
than seven people you know so
we i keep those things in mind and as um
i guess
leading with my wife
um i want to make sure that we're
hitting the marks and making sure
you know we're doing what we're supposed
to do with that said i have to make sure
i'm on point you know and i have to have
those conversations with myself every
morning to you know assess where we are
what are we doing for the day
and let's meet those goals today and
then that'll be a good day
yeah what happens when it slips like
because inevitably it does life happens
oh for sure i i we always have this joke
if it's a bad day you know hey go to bed
or something it'll it'll get better
that's good
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
around the resetting of your of your
energy
um i listen to a lot of abraham hicks
and it's always like you know the sort
of you start over in the morning and
it's like you know set the day you get
to you get to start over with your with
your energy and um
it's true sleeping on it's a real thing
yeah for sure i mean you know sometimes
you have to be
rested i mean we can fight our bodies
i'm i'm one of the main culprits of this
i just want to go go go go go
and then i'll hit the wall and then i'll
be mad because i'm not rested it's you
know it's all about finding that balance
um
and that's kind of one of the reasons
why i wanted to fall into
being uh you know full-time dad
full-time father and all that stuff
because
you know i found to be honest it was way
easier playing basketball you know
because
it's what i do
being a dad is what i do
you know playing basketball it was all
about i felt like it was all about me i
have to go to the gym
i need to
lace up my sneakers so i can have a good
game tomorrow you need to be quiet so i
can get rest which is great
people play their role my family plays
their role after that you know during
that time but after that
you know it kind of
it's more of a team thing now you know
now i have to go
to golf lessons and tennis lessons and
basketball lessons and be patient and
pack the lunches and
four you know
dry yeah four what was that like i mean
that's a big transition i mean you know
as athletes like i get you know spoken
to about kind of the dynamics within my
life and how things have gone but that's
for sure one of them is like you're so
focused and dedicated on your on what
you're doing
um and you need to be um so what peaked
i'm wondering like what kind of triggers
and what kind of things
what kind of things popped up that
you're like i better deal with this so
this is going to be a problem
well i mean
right away i saw the dynamic of the
household i have three boys and at the
time when i knew i wasn't gonna play
basketball anymore
um
my little ones were babies my twins were
babies but
still i'm i have a brother so i know how
uh you know boys in the household can be
and and how is that
what does that mean i don't i didn't
grow up with boys what was that oh it's
rambunctious high energy oh it's like
atoms bumping off of each other it's the
same exact thing
they're just
growing yeah and hungry yeah
[Laughter]
but you know for um that was one of the
things that helped ground me was taking
my son to school in the morning every
day he was in the first grade
and i had i was in the car pool every
day i'm fresh off of not playing
basketball
you know
people no doubt they had to have stopped
oh yeah they must have knocked on your
window they must have 100
i still get approached today um like oh
yeah you were in the car pool back yeah
we were hearing about you i wanted to
but but even then with my son that
wasn't enough
he said you know dad sometimes we get
there early say hey dad um
walk me to class
okay so i walk into class then after
that if the kids aren't and if
everybody's not in school yet uh yeah
pick up that book read that book for me
you know and we did that every morning
you know every morning and so
that kind of got me into a rhythm but it
also showed me being a part of the
community of the school
um and this is pretty pandemic of course
um
you know um
making sure that my son is getting
education that he needs
having that sense of knowing that it's
bigger than just me it's more
uh than just how i'm feeling or what i
want to do it's about what we want to do
as a collective so for me i need to make
sure that he's in a good head space
just you know so he can have a good day
at school and that was pretty much how i
started my day
personally professionally i didn't know
what was going on i didn't know what i
was going to do
um you know moving forward everything
had happened so sudden but
for sure for sure
that that 40-minute drive to school
reading that book and walking my son to
class that's kind of where i started and
then i came back and would uh uh write
just like journal
you know i did this yeah i did this for
weeks and weeks and months yeah
[Laughter]
and that's kind of how um this book came
about because i noticed when i got home
i would write
for a couple of hours and
i just noticed like man i don't really
like what i'm writing about you know i
don't like these words i don't like you
i don't like this let's change this and
i and and that made me realize where i
was mentally and and so you were asking
me that question earlier that was one of
the things i did to help me out i recall
free writing just free write
boom boom boom and then and then you
read it not cringe a little bit and say
yeah yeah okay let me get more to a mode
of appreciation for the journey as
opposed to being mad
that it's over because that's only a
fraction this life thing is much bigger